many humans they have jobs where they're
supposed to work eight hours a day but
the amount of work that they actually
have they could get done in two hours so
they have to pretend to work for the
other six hours so it's it's there's a
I'm reading this book called [ __ ]
jobs by David Graeber [ __ ] it's great
man but he just is you know addressing
the fact that we've gotten to the point
now where we really don't need to work
as much as we are
yeah but because the model of things is
that when we go to work we're selling
our time mm-hmm so ladies I go to work
I'm selling you eight hours of time
correct which means I'm your slave for
eight hours essentially and so within
that eight hours if there's downtime the
employer feels like he's getting ripped
off right so she's like no you can't
just sit and look at the internet even
though there's nothing to do yeah and so
you get punished for efficiency mm-hmm
if you can finish your job in two hours
you're gonna either lose six hours of
pay because you go home right or you're
gonna get chastised because you're
sitting around for the other six hours
so you have to start faking work and and
according to graver this is like one of
the most psychologically brutal things
that can happen to a human to fake what
you could do efficiently yeah because
it's BDSM because it's a form of BDSM
where you have to sit and VDS it means
the sort of people that don't know it's
like brutal know about BDSM it's a
bondage domination I guess BDSM and
sadomasochism right it's like a it's
like great I'm glad you asked me that
cuz it's so funny I I love it and I
don't even know what the [ __ ] acronym
it what it stands for oh I know like if
I see a picture of a lady with like a
like a whip and like some you know sharp
stuff and some catsuit and like yeah you
see like some guy who's married but it's
just stopping at her house for an hour
yeah I know that that's BDS that is BDSM
and I but I yeah but I don't know what
it means
bondage domination sadomasochism its
bondage and discipline discipline
so you're saying then so then having to
fake which you could be able to do just
to be able to keep your job in your pay
that's that that is brutal it's brutally
this person it's sick and if you don't
do it you're gonna get fired right so
you so the in and the in and so he's
writing on how the culture the way it
works is the employer knows that there's
not enough work so the the sickness of
it is you you have to you both kind of
have to lie to each other hmm
so not only are you having to do this
play act of pretending to work but
you're also like having to be dishonest
throughout the day you're having to
because he says like what what a define
Zab ol [ __ ] job is that it really
doesn't have any impact at all in the
world there's really no need for it to
exist but not just that the employee
knows that the job is not doing anything
is useless
Wow so you're you're many many people
are just stuck in this hell realm of
just essentially like pouring water out
of one cup into the other and then
pouring it back and then pouring it back
right and they're getting paid in a lot
of them get paid a lot of money yeah
that's the other thing he points out
which is really [ __ ] nuts which is it
the most essential jobs the Pete those
people get paid the least and the least
essential jobs those people get paid the
most yeah and then when you factor in
all the other um when you factor in the
fact that somebody got the mother the
easiest one cuz his [ __ ] dad was
somebody like it just yeah it just
probably just creates so much angst yeah
exactly right yeah but then we don't
serve and the next step is is automation
because it's the next step is automation
means that the next step is that where
we're at yeah so the next step is gonna
look like I mean theoretically it's
gonna look like AI is going to get to
the point where it can start doing like
accounting and like law mm-hmm so not
like trial lawyers but most law involves
like you know creating a will or just
thrill it's it's law's code laws code
right so AI is gonna get to the point
where it can create a will for you
create a prenup for you create a you
know do all the [ __ ] that you would have
to go to a human force and it's not just
that it's like gonna do the same thing
for accounting it's going to do the same
thing for pretty much anything that's
big
based on code right anything is based on
some of those books where there's not a
lot of you know where it doesn't have to
be argued exactly where it's kind of set
in stone and you already see that with
like LegalZoom you already see the the
little elements of that that are
reaching out to the people that are
connecting us and yeah we don't know
what goes on next thing you know you
have a patent right next thing you know
you have a you know you have an LLC set
up exactly yeah so it's like that so
people think that automation means oh
yeah okay so we're gonna lose all the
all the the the taxi industry is gonna
be completely automated and fast food
chains well that'll be completely
automated and that's really sad cuz
fast-food workers they don't get paid
enough money for the work they do they
have these shitty jobs
yeah I'll tip I'm a lot of times I'll
throw over the lady ten bucks and we
should like we should I mean this is
this is a hell job yeah that's the other
really crazy thing about our society is
we look down on those people so there's
a judgement if you work at McDonald's
right here you're looked you're shamed
for that job and but your job is [ __ ]
hard and it sucks and and somebody and
there's always not doing [ __ ] right
[ __ ] Lawrence by the fries is never
[ __ ] do it [ __ ] he's trying to [ __ ]
right he's not doing any why Woody's
days barely getting paid he's burning
his skin
you know Eva Roberta his stupid jerk
hairs he's picking up his extra because
she wants to get promoted yeah so it's
this sick vortex of like no could the
same drama of game of Game of Thrones
it's taking place in McDonald's where
people are in this microcosm game of
fries game of fries but you see them
when you're at the front desk do you
know you see like there's usually like a
Latino woman or like kind of like a
middle-aged black woman that's like or
like a redheaded kind of white lady that
hasn't been outside and alone to them
and they're like the leader there like
devout and they have like the little
yeah you know even a little tie up thing
at the top of the other dress or smock
yeah and then you see like somebody over
by the window biggest headset [ __ ]
furious yes you know ya Breton in people
yeah it's a hell realm and there
and the the meat is sizzling and this
all the weird chemicals are blowing into
their face all day and and it's like a
making me hungry yeah it's delicious
food but it's a hell rum and so you're
saying that we so we have these jobs now
and people are living in these worlds
right right yeah so that's gonna become
automated so yeah so that's so what no
so what happens is the fast-food workers
rightfully want to get paid more because
they're like this is ridiculous that I'm
not getting paid a living wage yeah and
so the people who are running the
franchises and running the corporations
know that it wants it I have to start
paying my workers $20 an hour for 25 or
23 or $17 an hour at some point the
amount I have to pay them becomes more
expensive than the amount I would have
to pay to implement robots automation
and so at that point it becomes
pointless to use a human anymore right
so that that's what called a market
pressure right so once it crosses past
whatever that boundary is that pushes us
closer to full automation so those
people now don't have jobs and the uber
drivers don't have jobs but not just the
uber drivers the truck drivers don't
have jobs anymore right so in Knott
central I don't take away my truckers
when I'm gone don't so that's gone and
now when the truck drivers don't have
jobs guess what goes next the [ __ ]
truck stops and all the little towns and
that are built on the economy of trucks
stopping on the highway yes I'll hop and
get a smoothie up and get a jerk off
whatever yeah well let me come over
there I could get some gas and come over
here I understand that is exactly right
although all of those what are they what
a trucker prostitutes called a lot
lizards they called a lot lizards yeah
all the lot lizards they have to go
slithering where there's going to be a
[ __ ] it's gonna be like a refugee
crisis lot was it just slithering into
Vegas right okay yeah just this huge up
in Sedona slithering through the rocks
and just rising up over Vegas just and
that's it [ __ ] yeah and what are we
going to do with them you know what are
we gonna do with all the lot lizards
this is the future these are the
in the future what's up guys sitting
here with this marijuana plant I think
also could be just a regular plant it
could be poison ivy brother lots of
smoke myself in some itchy itchy just
watch another clip since you're already
here you know I'm saying